Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right. What's going on guys. This is.
Rob and we are picking back up again with the three jokers. Yes.
This is the conclusion to the three jokers storyline. Right?
Keep in mind that one of the jokers is dead.
The clown joker is the one that was killed by, by Jason Todd,
the criminal and the comedian are still alive. But in this video,
we are going to find out which one of these jokers is the real joker.
And it's amazing. It's such a great review.
So initially this kind of picks up with like Batman and Jason,
Todd and Barbara Gordon kind of conversing right about all the information that
they've seen. Right. You know,
the information that was kind of brought together and the fact that the joker
wanted them to find all this stuff, right? The three jokers, one of these guys,
one of these, these three to find all these things that are here.
And so one of the things that that was kind of established in the last video is
that the jokers are created.
Two of these jokers were artificially created in the sense that we have one main
joker and then he created the other two.
And so the idea is that if that's true and the question is which joker is the
real one, right? And that's really where,
whether where they're trying to figure out.
And one of the things that Jason Todd says is whichever joker is the real joker.
Once I find them, like once I set my sights on him, there'll be no jokers.
I'm going to kill him because you're too weak to do it Batman.
And when that happens, Bruce Wayne freaks out, right?
Like he immediately loses it and starts going after Jason, Todd.
And the reason why, and this, this is what's so cool.
I'm gonna be honest with you guys. This is what's so cool.
I think this is the best that Jason Todd's been written in years.
I'm just going to say it. But one of the things that, that,
that man gets out about up his off about is like,
do you really think that I haven't wanted to put a,
put a bullet in the brain of the joker, right?
Do you think I really didn't want to kill him after everything that he did after
he, what he did to you after what he did to Barbara, do you really think,
I didn't want to? And the response of Jason Todd is,
but you didn't have all the talk that you have. You didn't do it. You wanted to,
you could have, but you didn't. And that's one of the things that's interesting,
right?
Like whenever I make this point about how Batman should kill his villains,
people usually kind of default to the slippery slope argument.
I never really consider that a good argument. It's a fallacy because one,
it assumes that you can't control yourself. Right?
You'd assume that you can't say like, I'm just going to stop here.
The problem with the slippery slope argument is that if you apply it to across
the board and you say, okay,
let's apply this slippery slope argument to anything, then we can say, okay,
you should never have a single drink of alcohol in your life. Because if you do,
it's a slippery slope and you'll become an alcoholic.
You should never smoke weed once in your life. Because if you do,
it's a slippery slope and you'll become a drug addict, right?
That's the problem with the slippery slope argument, right?
It assumes that Batman couldn't sit down and reason and say, okay,
of all the villains that I have joker is by and far the worst,
because he just kills people, indiscriminately,
for reasons that don't make sense to anybody but himself,
but has something to do with the fact that he wants me to come and find him.
And for every time I captured the joker,
he'll kill a hundred people before I get him.
So we should just kill him and be done with it. It assumes Batman.
Can't define that reason, right? Batman can't say, okay, killing the joker.
That's basically where it stops. Right?
I can't justify killing the penguin or anybody like that because they're just,
they're they're criminals, right? They do some pretty shady stuff,
but nobody's as bad as the joker is for the world's greatest detective.
I have a hard time believing. He'd be unable to stop at that line of logic.
So that's why I never really paid any attention to the slippery slope argument
and just kind of ignored it because it's the argument you make when you can't
make any other argument.
But the crazy thing about this is that Batman basically says like you don't
understand, right?
Barbara Gordon tries to step in and kind of mediate things a little bit.
But at the end of the day, they're both ignoring her. It's Jason, Todd,
and Batman. And at the end of the day, Batman's like, you don't understand you.
You never have understood Batman. Doesn't say it in so many words,
but Jason Todd does not understand the effect it had on Bruce Wayne.
And the reason why is because their children to persuade they're his kids.
That's just, that's, that's the,
that's just the plain and simple statement of the fact, right? Sure.
Barbara Gordon has her dad, right? She's got commissioner Gordon,
but Batman sees them as children, especially Jason, Todd, Tim Drake,
and Dick Grayson there's kids. Like he would,
he took them on his wards by all standards of measurement.
He was their father or father figure.
And he was there to make sure that no harm befell them.
He knew the risk that he was taking here,
but he also understood that they needed to have an outlet for their anger and
their visions and their desire to destroy. They needed a good way to channel it.
And, and the best way to channel it is to one,
allow them to help him on his missions. But to,
to curb that desire for revenge into a desire to make people's lives better.
And so, along the way, Jason, Todd kind of seemed to have gotten lost,
but Jason Todd was beaten to death.
And when Jason Todd came back and he was so angry at Batman because Batman
didn't kill the joker Batman wanted to,
but he didn't because in his mind it wasn't the right thing to do.
And so the results of this is that you kind of have this little bit of a
breakdown, right? The Batman runs over the criminal joker and says,
he's very reminiscent of the joker from the early days.
Like the old Bob Kane bill finger joker, right?
Like the guy who was just really sadistic, really dark the clown.
Of course they face it, the aquarium and Jason Todd killed him.
The comedian is the one where you see him laugh,
but there's just something there, right?
There's just kind of like this darkness,
this dark sadistic streak behind the laugh and the smile and the eyes,
it just shows this guy is the worst of them all.
He's the absolute worst of the jokers, the most violent of all the jokers.
And so because of that, it's okay. One of these three is the original joker.
Maybe we already killed them in the aquarium.
Maybe it's the criminal mastermind. Maybe it's the comedian, right.
Maybe it's the most, the district of the mall. But whichever one, it is,
one of them is the real joker is the question of Barbara Gordon is maybe we
finally find out, well, maybe we find out the true origin of the joker.
And at the end of the day, like Jason, Todd is like,
maybe just some kind of a nobody. Right.
But where the questions asked like Batman, do you know who the joker is? Right?
Like, do you know his name? Irresponsive Bruce is no. If I did know,
I would have told you already.
And so what you end up doing is picking up in the aftermath of Joe Hill being
kidnapped. Right? We saw that in the,
in the last video that we did in the last comic that we did that Joe chill was
kidnapped from black gate prison while he was basically going through medical
treatment and Batman immediately wants to see a cell.
Now here's the crazy thing is Batman's going through these,
these kind of books that were in the cell of Joe till he came across letters
that Joe chil wrote, and none of the letters were ever mailed out,
but they were all made out to Bruce Wayne. And so where he,
he basically ends up going to see Reverend Evans, right?
The guy who essentially runs the show, kind of, you know, this, this priest,
you know, who helps them find repentance of their, that he's not the warden,
but the person that helps them basically helps prisoners kind discover who they
really are or allows them to repent or whatever the case is that when Batman is
talking to him, he basically says, you know, he says, no,
like these letters were never nailed because they were never finished. You know,
he dropped out of school when he was 13 and he was doing his best in his classes
here, but his learning disabilities slowed him down. Right.
His inability to read at an effective rate, you know, at an effective level.
And that these letters that he wrote were long before he became ill,
because the thought of Batman and he kind of went down and wants to deviate to
the idea that Joe chill is still just a bad person. It comforts him.
And that's why Batman says, okay.
So if the whole reason he wrote these letters is because he got sick and he just
wanted to, he wanted to repent, right?
Like he wanted to make sure he didn't go to hell when he died.
And the responsive of Reverend Evans. No,
he wrote those long before he fell ill a long time ago. He felt ill.
Now the other part of this is you pick up with Barbara Gordon and you pick up
with,
with Dick Grayson while Batman's inside talking to the Reverend and Dick race.
And initially kind of hits up Barbara Gordon and says, look, uh, you know,
I know I kind of screwed up here, right? Like,
I've put you guys in a rough position, but at the end of the day,
he also tells her like we won't ever have anything like that again. And it's,
it's kind of an important thing here because it gives us a little bit of a
softer side of, of Jason Todd.
And so it's a little bit nuts there because the question that Reverend has is
what do they want with him? What, like, why take Joe chill in the first place?
Right. He's a dying man. Like he literally has cancer. His days are numbered.
And he basically says like,
I'm going to find out because what he finds among all these letters,
as one that was obviously written by the joker,
and it basically has a ticket to the Mark of Zorro. And so again, that's at the,
the Monarch theater.
That was the show that Batman and his parents are Bruce Wayne.
His parents were going to see when they died or had seen when they died.
And so of course, Barbara Gordon and Bruce Wayne and,
and Jason Todd showed up here and this begins,
what's probably the single greatest point in this whole story. Well,
greatest moment in this entire story that when you have him show up,
a movie begins to play. And this movie is,
is basically like the comedian joker talking to Joe chill and saying, okay,
kind of picking up where we left off in the last one.
Why did you really kill Thomas and Martha Wayne? I've read all your letters.
I've read the ministers. No, you've seen the light, right? Your,
your experiences and the suffering that you cause have, have touched your soul.
They've touched your immortal soul.
And you have looked to repent all of your sins, but answer something for me.
Why did you kill Thomas and Martha Wayne? Really?
What was the motivation behind it? Now,
Batman of course ends up kind of making his way through the theater as this
movies playing. And then finally comes across judge Hill.
Who's currently being held by the criminals.
And this is cool because the criminal is not being written as like a crazy goofy
guy. Right?
That was one of the cool things about his character is he's methodical.
He thinks he focuses that he, that it hurts him to laugh,
which I think is probably one of the greatest additions to the joker mythos
ever.
But what he says here is their initial intention was to turn Jason Todd into the
new joker. But the problem with that is that Jason Todd lacks sophistication,
and then they were going to take Barbara Gordon, but she's got too much heart,
right? So he picked the killer. Uh, he picked Joe Hill.
The intention is to turn Joe chill into a new joker.
And it's one of the things that's kind of nuts here is because while this little
bit of a segment's happening between criminal joker in between, you know,
Batman,
that you've also got the comedian joker doing that interview with Joe chill,
and then they record it.
And they're putting on the movie screen and George Hill to kind of nip this in
the bud real quick. So we can kind of focus on the meat and potatoes of this.
Joe chill.
The reason why he killed Thomas and Martha Wayne is because he was struggling.
He was down on his luck and he saw them.
And he believed that people who were that rich are the reason why he was that
poor. It was their fault.
And so he wanted to take some of what they had in order to get himself back on
his feet again.
And the result of that was that once he got there and once he essentially went
to go Rob them, he suddenly realized that Bruce Wayne's there.
And before he knew it, the gun was going off, right? The gun was going off.
And the result was that they were basically killed,
but it wasn't until after everything that was going on.
Did he realize that Thomas and Martha Wayne,
which he already knew who they were,
but they were actually people who were using their money to make Gotham city
better.
But they were looking to work against those individuals who use their wealth to
buy politicians, to make laws in their favor, things like that.
They were the good guys and he killed two people who were actually looking to
make Gotham better, who could have made his life better,
but in his anger and in his selfishness,
he kind of categorized them all the same.
Everybody out there who's rich is the reason why I'm poor, right?
And there really isn't a direct corollary between those two things.
It's not necessarily because somebody is rich, you are poor, right?
It's not necessarily that way, but Joe Hill saw it that way.
And that's what led him to committing the act that he debt.
Now that admission will become much more important later on down the line.
But Batman initially approaches Joe chill with the intention of Framingham and
criminal joker reveals. He's got his whole chest strap with dynamite.
Now that's a classic move for the criminal joker.
If you go back and you read the old, uh, the old Bob Kane bill finger stories,
right? Do you ever get your chance? You know, you can, you can buy them on.
I think you can buy them directly from DC, or you can grab on Comixology.
You can go read those super old Batman stories, right? Batman number one,
number two, number three, go read those really old stories with the joker.
And that's the kind of stuff he would do. And so you end up having, you know,
Barbara Gordon and Jason Todd facing off against like these kind of joke,
arise people, right? These, these joke arise, individuals who are out there,
but as Barbara Gordon is facing off against a couple of them,
they both get shot. And when she initially believes it's Jason Todd,
she turns around and is the comedian joker, the one who shot her, right?
The one who shot her from killing joke to steel wheeling,
that same camera that he had his outfits different,
but he's still got the same camera and he's like time for you to smile.
And so it was like a great tribute to the killing joke, right?
It's like an amazing tribute to the killing joke. And so the,
the motivation behind creating a new joker and even the motivation behind the
creation of these jokers is revealed when the criminal tells Batman,
he wants to be more, he needs to be everything to Batman.
The biggest issue that he has with Batman is he's not his main focus.
Now that's a, that's a common point that Joker's had over the years.
It's not something Jeff Johns is making up on the spot.
That's been the motivation behind joker for years for eons and eons and eons
that he wants to be. The one that Batman focuses on.
He wants to be the center of Batman's life.
He almost in kind of a sadistic and screwed up legs.
He's Batman is like a lover is a dissatisfaction, right?
The fact that he doesn't have Batman focusing on him in that way,
leaves him dissatisfied. And so initially that his response is Joe chose a sick,
dying old man of what use would he be to you?
And that's when criminal joker says,
I'm willing to bet that this little bath will put them into remission.
I'm willing to bet if we don't come in this water that is going to cure his
cancer, it'll make him insane,
but it'll cure his cancer and he will be one of us.
And that's kind of the crazy thing here, right?
That's kind of the crazy situation,
because right now this criminal joker defines the concept of the joker as an
undefined chaos. We're just absolute chaos.
There's no rhyme and reason to us be like,
you don't see us as like a form and a function, right?
You don't see us as we truly are, that we are the antithesis to you. Instead,
you see us as just like crazy guys who implement some schemes and do some things
and I'll help hops off for a little while. And then things go back to normal,
right? Like you capture us and then we go to jail and that's basically it,
but I need to be more, we as a joker need to be more. And so at that point,
like literally joker pulls out a Tommy gun goes to shoe Batman, of course,
Batman Dodgers, out of the way. But in the process, the robes start to snap.
The joker falls, the lighter falls out of his hand and ends up,
ends up landing in this VAT of chemicals, which of course turns us this great,
big, huge chemical thing on fire. And so in that moment, when,
when criminal joker goes to fight Bruce Wayne, you've also got, uh,
the comedian joker facing off against Barbara Gordon.
And it's just kind of like, I've never, I haven't had this much fun in a long,
long time and we're just getting started.
And when part of the roof begins to collapse and it doesn't quite kill Barbara
Gordon then, but when part of the roof starts to collapse,
the comedian ends up bailing out, right. He ends up taking off.
And so you've got the criminal joker facing off against Batman.
He goes to cut the wire so that, uh,
judge Hill will fall inside the burning chemical bath, right?
Like the water has to be on fire in order for it to fully effect, right.
In order for it to fully take effect, but he cuts him loose.
And then Batman saves Joe chill.
And that's the crazy thing is the criminal was not relying on Batman saving
judge Hill,
that he was kind of relying on Batman's hatred of Joe chil to just let him die
right now.
I wouldn't necessarily say that Batman saves Joe chill because he's on a lot of
them killed not to let anybody not. You know,
I think it's really more of Batman saves Joe chill because he doesn't want to
deal with another joker. I think that's really what kind of goes on here.
But of course he ends up swinging back into action going after the criminal
again. And then once what's the criminal's temporarily knocked out,
Joe chill kind of looks at Batman is like, I know who you are.
They talk about you and black gate. And you know what I did in this place,
are you going to kill me? And it's a little bit ambiguous here, right?
It's a little bit ambiguous here.
It's one of these things where Joe chill almost kind of wants Batman to kill
him. I mean, well, I guess it's not really ambiguous. He says I deserve it,
but it's almost kind of like he wants Batman to kill him.
But the cool thing about this is Joe chill is exceedingly remorseful for his
actions.
And that's an important thing because Batman's initial response is like, no,
I'm not going to kill you. And that's when Joe's feels like I deserve it.
I'm truly sorry for what I did this combined with with Batman's knowledge of the
fact that judge Hill had written these letters before he became sick indicates
that he really is remorseful. He's not remorseful because he's on his last days.
He really does feel terrible about what he did because Joe chill,
one turned the life of Bruce Wayne upside down and two doomed Gotham.
He made Gotham what it is by getting rid of Thomas and Martha Wayne and allowing
corruption among the police and among politicians and among the ultra wealthy to
run Supreme. He made Gotham the way that it is.
He single handedly screwed up the whole town.
And so it's kind of crazy because of course the bricks start to fall and then
Batman rescues him again. And you know, he says, thank you about,
and I was like, you're welcome. But in that moment,
the criminal pops back up again. Right? And he says like,
I'd hope to extend this game more. But now we all go together right.
And gets ready to pull this, the stick of dynamite, any shot by the comedian.
But the comedian shoots him in the head and says, and then there was one,
take me away. Bats arrest me and take me away.
Now the big question here is why even kill him?
Why even kill them in the first place? Why kill the criminal? Well,
the reason for this comes after Barbara Gordon,
Jason Todd Shira moment where Jason Todd's kind of pits about Batman,
just kind of sitting in back to the bad cave,
but he also asked Barbara Gordon really a chance about us, right?
Because remember like this year to kiss and Barbara was like, no, you know,
he gets friends zone basically as a year, you'd make a really good friend.
You know, I don't know what to tell you. I don't feel that way about you. Right.
He just basically gets shut down. And so of course, you know,
the two of them ended up going their separate ways temporarily,
but Batman starts having a conversation with the joker and the joker says like,
he's, he's literally see now, after all of that drama, don't you feel better,
Bruce. Right? Bruce Wayne, Barbara Gordon, Jason, Todd. You know, I know,
but I don't care. I'm not going to tell anybody, right.
The world can never know your true name. You might stop doing this. If I do,
right. If I tell people who you really are, right, you might quit.
And that really kind of solidifies a lot of what was established in Scott.
Snyder's new 52 Batman run that the joker doesn't care about Bruce Wayne's
identity as Batman.
But what he cares about is the cat and mouse game that they chase each other
around. They just go round and round and round in circles.
The funny thing about this is when Batman asked the question,
what is it that you want? Right? The joker says, what do I want?
Certainly not what the others did. The clown,
your troubled Robin put a bullet in.
All he wanted to do was laugh at the suffering of others. How common right?
And the criminal old man was so delusional.
This whole great big idea of creating a better joker. Well, that's just lunacy,
right? A defined joker one with a name and identity.
That ruins the very definition of me. That's why I regret making him.
Or he says, does it do, does he regret making me the reality of this?
If I'm really a betting man here, this is the original joker.
The comedian is the original joker. And his comes in a couple different ways.
Like what Batman says, what's the punchline. The joker says, that's the point.
There's no final twist, right?
Not until I decide to put my knife into your heart.
But he says a criminal was absolutely wrong. I am chaos, right? I'm the devil.
I'm nothing in everything to you. The joker is not the one who's broken.
It's Batman, who's broken. All of this was basically my plant.
Batman was broken by a greater pain than any of us could ever inflict on you.
And so I convinced them that making Joe chill,
the new joker would be the best idea. Like the man who destroyed Gotham,
the man who destroyed you,
making him into the joker into like another joker would push you,
but it would destroy you on some level, in a way that I never really could.
And the irony behind all this is, he says like,
you save the man who kills your parents,
who said the city literally spiraling down into your, into despair.
This man apologized to you, which is exactly what you needed to hear. And so,
because of me, your greatest wound has been healed.
And so now I can be your greatest pain. I will cut. You. I'll hurt you all.
I'll destroy your life in every way that I possibly can because
now I am your only real focus you're dealt with Joe chill. You dealt with that,
that pain and that struggle and that anger that you've been carrying around all
your life, that wound is now healed. Now there's the wounds that I can create.
I can become your source.
I can become your source of anger and your source of pain.
I can become the thing that you hate the most in this world.
I am now your main focus. That was the whole plan behind this, right?
That was the whole basis behind this. It's an amazing reveal.
But Bruce Wayne of course goes to visit Joe Hill and basically accepts Joe
chills apology. Right? The two of them actually ended up holding hands,
which is a massive moment.
And he actually holds the hand of judge Hill as he dies.
And so while Batman didn't necessarily tell Joe Hill in that alleyway,
I forgive you.
This is Bruce Wayne appearing to Joe chill as Joe chil needed for Bruce Wayne to
appear to him and say, I forgive you for what you've done.
Forgiveness is what Bruce Wayne needed to heal himself.
And it's what Joe chil needed to finally be able to come to terms of what it was
that he did. George Hill of course dies.
And he ends up being buried and then Batman or Bruce Wayne ends up traveling to
Alaska. And he basically says,
you kind of have this a little bit of a statement.
The world can never know your true name.
You end up having this bit of a conversation that Batman has with Alfred. Now,
there is also a letter that, that,
that red hood leaves her Barbara Gordon and says it like,
I want to make a change, right?
But I came to that without you basically like it's a confession of love is a
confession of love that he needs Barbara Gordon.
The problem is like the letter falls off a wall and ends up being swept away by
just some random guy. So she never got the letter. And Jason Todd says,
I'll never bring it up. If you never say anything to me,
then I'll assume you toilet letter up and threw it away.
And I'll never ask you about it. If you never come to me and talk about it,
I'll never come to you.
And I'll assume that if you never came to me and talked to me about it,
that you didn't want to be a part of my life in that way,
that you didn't want to love me in that way,
that you didn't want us to become something it's actually tragic. Right?
It's insanely tragic, right? Because if I'm being honest,
as weird as it is that Robert Gordon and Jason Todd kiss,
because they're kind of like adopted brother and sister,
I guess I could kind of ship them, you know, see them going together.
I don't really know, but Batman ends up having a conversation with Alfred.
And the crazy thing about this is you basically have Bruce Wayne talking to
Alfred insane. I don't mean to sound the way that people think I do,
but like I'm Batman, right? I knew the Joker's name one week after we first met,
I've known his identity the entire time. And then you get these little moments,
these little scenes that come from a killing joke.
And basically like you end up having the wife of the joker we're in the killing
joke. The joke, the explanation to the Joker's wife was that he died.
The reality of this is that it looks as though that's not true that she was
actually sent away because it looked like she would never, ever,
ever be free of the joker.
How the nature of these two guys consolidates with the way they were depicted.
Right? Because they refer to the jokers, like sir, different things like that.
Doesn't quite make a whole lot of sense, you know, but, but anyway,
she's basically talking to cops and he wind up having, you know,
having her basically escorted away.
Essentially it looked like her death was faked, right.
But she ends up getting away from, from, you know,
the joker before he became the joker.
And she ends up traveling to Alaska where she's been this entire time with her
kid that she's raising. And so what this points to, and what,
and what I'm going with, this is the real joker out of all, three of these guys,
the real joker is the killing joke, joker, the criminal joker and the, the,
the clown joker. They were created by the comedian, right?
They were created by him and that they're not actually jokers.
They were just two random guys out there who, for whatever reason,
the comedian joker chose. So the comedian is the true joker, right?
The origin of the killing joke is the actual origin of the joker. Right.
And it makes sense. That's the one that fans go with the most,
but that's where things stand right now, killing Joe joker.
That story is the original origin of the joker. He is the original joker, right?
So with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to comments,
explain to make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob
core. If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a light.
Now we'll catch you all later.
Bruce.